you know one feature on youtube i do
genuinely want removed well and i don't
know if i'm i would be the only one here
the your video is this ranked out of 10
of your previous 10 videos
no i i like i i understand it does serve
a use
but i don't i don't know i i i'm like
indifferent to it because it's like it
it depends on how well the video it did
really
where it's like the point where it's
like the point where it's like if i see
a video
and it's like your video got less views
from your
frequent viewers nine out of ten when
it's just like [ __ ] this system but then
when it's like
one out of ten and you see those
fireworks you're like damn i'm good
i think we've explained the system about
before yeah recap real quickly youtube
ranks your videos and how they're doing
against
your other videos the past ten videos it
ranks them one out of ten one yeah the
best 10 being the worst
i actually quite like it as much as i
hate it i like it i think it's good you
know um
i before i remember did you just have
like an estimate in your head of what
was good
views yeah yeah yeah for me it was like
if i get so and so views
in the first 24 hours good view if it's
over that great video with that is that
that you know your average of what i
expect video to get is never
static and that number is always
changing and i think it's good because
i don't know what i should be aiming for
and at least this has kind of helped me
like set expectations and figure out
okay
you know it's it's been a really good
way of figuring out personally all right
if something's number 10 all right let
me let me go and re-evaluate that yeah
it [ __ ] sucks i'm not happy about it
yeah and sometimes i genuinely do think
it was a
really [ __ ] good video they got
[ __ ] just by one reason or another
um but most of the time i do feel like
it's been really helpful
as much as it makes me want to just like
quit i feel though like
it's kind of a double-edged sword in
that case though because i remember
where
you know when you have like say a really
[ __ ] good streak right of like
one to two months of worth of videos
that are just a banger after banger
after banger that's like all
over perfectly you know you're in the
stock market you're bubbling
you know you know the fall is coming yes
and then you're like i'm i'm expecting
the fall where's the fall
and then you wake up the next morning
and your newest video is like nine out
of ten or even like a ten out of ten
right yeah and you're like well [ __ ]
this is the end of my cruise but then
when you look at that video
like in retrospect if you just say screw
it to the other nine videos let me just
look at this video on its own
right and it's actually doing okay it
just feels like the video is like crap
because your other nine videos were just
over performing right yeah you want to
hear a big bang big brain strap just
make a [ __ ] video
it's like a [ __ ] video right you got it
you purposely
all my ideas are you know mostly good
sometimes i'll make a video and it comes
out [ __ ] yeah and then i'm like you know
what
fine have a 10 out of 10. put my
expectations down
release reset the x-men i'm like yeah
i'm like let's just let's just [ __ ]
let's humble myself for a moment here
let's just upload a [ __ ] video
i've uploaded videos where i thought
like oh my god what am i doing yeah and
then like
i've also had the opposite happen where
i'm like this is a 10 out of 10 video
and i'm like this is god
really yeah unwatchable and it literally
got like one out of ten and i'm like i
[ __ ] hate it here
yeah this video shocked i've had that
before the worst ones are like
damn this is gonna be a banger video
nine out of ten yeah
yeah oh nothing feels worse nothing
feels worse feels worse
like my entire like i do check that in
the morning once the video goes yeah i
see that and i'm just like
entire day ruined yeah just like that i
guess what i think is that
maybe like i do see usefulness in it so
i don't think it should be removed but
i think it should be harder to find
because it's like front and center
it is literally the funniest thing you
see the first literally the first thing
you see
when you log in right to your account
and you're
like youtube's either giving you a clap
or being like son
i expect it better from you what the
[ __ ] is wrong
man i don't know i can't i think it's
all right i think where it is is joke
fine honestly i
i i this is how you like personally
perceive it right
i i think it very much takes a
you have to kind of take your emotions
out of it a little bit to really
appreciate it
i mean that sounds so robotic you have
to be like i think you just have to
appreciate the data for what it is
like i mean all it is is neatly
packaging
the the truth you're hiding from
yourself in a way that is digestible
within 10 seconds
i think you know that's that's that's
the uh that's the was it
healthy advice to be like yo you you
just get over it
just not be sure just stop being sad
just don't be emotional
just why are you feeling emotions
because like you know it's just your
livelihood
i mean we we've talked about before like
how you know a lot of youtubers before
said they don't care about the views but
you know you do have like
as much as you want to think that you
are not emotionally attached to your
content and the numbers around your
content
it you do care at some level you do care
and it's not like
i i think you just have you would have
to be like a heartless robot to
make something you're proud of and not
care about how many people
view it right the way i see it it's like
i don't care if i spill my drink
but i care if i spill my drink and it
wrecks my pc
and [ __ ] everything up right right i
feel like there's an acceptable amount
of
[ __ ] up that i'm like ah i'll deal
with that right right if i get one ten
out of ten
all right well all right you know it
happens it happens something's gonna be
ten out of ten well yeah of course
two ten out of tens in a row all right
okay
you know it happens sometimes you know
yeah yeah yeah three ten out of ten i'm
okay all right well okay what is going
on
yeah that's when i started that's when
it starts to affect me that's yeah but
the first one i don't really let it
affect me i'm like you know what like
just statistics are just saying that
this is gonna happen eventually like
right no i completely get that right
like of course eventually you're gonna
have to get i love
math and you know i appreciate it no i
do too don't get me wrong but like you
know
i know i know that eventually this
streak or whatever it is i'm on
is gonna eventually run out right yeah
and then and you know even then if you
think about it right the more you're
getting five out of ten six editions
yeah all you're doing is making it
closer and closer
right so if you're getting one out of
tens or ten out of tens every time
you're making a like
famine or feast situation which is fine
but what i'm at right now at least my
past few videos have all been around
like give or take
like minimal percentage away from each
other like the difference between third
and eight for me is nothing
yeah yeah so like at that point i'm like
i don't even feel bad about any of it
ninth or third it's barely any
difference to me so why is youtube
trying to [ __ ] feel bad about it stop
that
no but because there's there's another
factor that i feel like this
doesn't take like account for and that's
like a long-term performance of a video
because some of my videos some of my
videos that have been a 9 10 out of 10
have gone on to grown to be like some of
my some of my most popular videos
and i feel like it what this what this
system
like really emphasizes is how well video
does short term where as youtube as you
as as like a content creator has been on
the platform for a very long time
i know that short term performance
doesn't mean a lot
but like no matter what no matter if i
make a video that i'm proud of and i
think it's going to perform well long
term
i still feel [ __ ] about it if it just is
that nine or ten hours
we need one out of your whole channel
uploads
like one out of like 1 000 or whatever
how many uploads you have right
i mean i think that's just going on to
the videos and looking up most popular
yeah yeah
but then but then you'll always feel
good because you'll never have like a
lowest one ever again because you'll
never have less views
like youtube come on like whenever
you're feeling bad you're just like let
me just go check out my most
videos of all time you know what i still
got it